Speaker 1: Let's go next to Tristin from Boston.
We've had a lot of technical issues with Tristan
from Boston in the past. Let's see if we
can hear from Tristan today, Tristan. Go.
Speaker 5: A David, can you hear me
Speaker 1: now,
I can, Tristan.
Speaker 5: Awesome. So.
I was, but we do ask you a question that actually
you brought up a couple of live streams ago
earlier this week or was it last week and it
was from Hillary Clinton where she brought up,
she floated the idea of possibly suing Tucker
Carlson over on Fox News because if there?
Their constant battering of her.
Unidentified:
Over, you know, the.
Speaker 5:
The to put Hillary got a lock her up, the
constant Hillary disinformation campaign
that had the Republicans and Trump have been
running since 2015 effectively. Mm hmm. Now if?
If in kind of an ideal world, I
would say if she or some other.
Huge figure. Took Fox News to court over that,
and she ended up winning a. Case. What do you
think the ripple effect would be for that?
Speaker 1: I have said that if any of these
people or media outlets lose a defamation suit, I
think it would do a ton to change these sometimes
multi-year campaigns of disinformation against
people. I mean, if it really hurt Fox financially
to have pushed lies about Hillary Clinton
that a court found were defamation
and they were really damaged by it financially.
I think they would have no choice but to revisit
their approach. Now they, of course, would claim
censorship and they would claim all of these
different things. But when when Hillary Clinton
mentions actual malice, which is, you know,
related to defamation, if they were to lose such
a suit, I think it would completely change what
these media outlets are willing to put on the air.
Speaker 5: Yeah, that's I mean, that's what
the kind of reminds me of when
Hannity. Let's say in Tulsa.
Yeah, you kind of got it back off this really
obvious Putin. Standing. Yesterday. Mm hmm.
When? It was really, really obvious that she
was doing this or we. We might, you know,
get accused of being Russia operatives, right?
Speaker 1: Absolutely, Kristen from Boston, thank
you so much for the call. We're going to take
a very quick break if you're holding on to talk
to me. Hold on just a little bit longer because
we'll go right back to the phones after this.